je peux pas marcher loin donc je peux
pas les prendre le bus donc je peux pas
me déplacer vraiment donc j'ai la chance
d'avoir quelqu'un qui vient me chercher
tous les jours et d'avoir quelqu'un qui
à mes côtés mais si j'avais pas cette
personne là comment je fais je reste
chez moi
j'ai même un métro
alors vous êtes ici ce soir donc pour
nous parler de la sclérose en plaques si
si c'est très étrange pour moi d'être là
parce que d'habitude je suis là pour
dire des conneries si tu arrives à nous
faire marrer avec la sclérose en plaques
chapeau c'est sûr je pense que je serai
pas marre avec la cirrhose en plaques
puis c'est pas le but du jeu mais voilà
c'est assez intimidant voilà alors il y
a 15 ans que tu te bats contre cette
maladie ça en est où quand j'ai eu ma
maladie une amie m'a dit un jour cette
maladie tu la traite de deux manières ou
comme une ennemi ou comme une amie une
amie c'est tu restes au lit était malade
un ami si tu te lèves tous les matins et
tu te bats tous les matins
il y a des matins ou c'est difficile
j'ai du matin ou c'est difficile des
matins c'est moins difficile et puis moi
j'ai la chance de m'être organisé une
vie parce que j'ai gagné de l'argent qui
fait que ma vie est plus facile que pour
d'autres qui ont moins d'argent qui sont
seuls c'est pour ça que je fais ça
aujourd'hui aussi ah c'est une maladie
qui a été décrite depuis le 19e siècle
au départ par Sarko mais dans l'origine
reste inconnue il y a à la fois des
prédispositions génétiques et puis à la
fois des facteurs environnementaux mais
on sait pas très bien d'où ça vient en
fait c'est une maladie très bizarre ça
touche plus les femmes que les hommes
plus le nord que le sud on ne sait pas
si on se pense que s'il y a un facteur
génétique sur et certain mais où il est
on ne sait pas est-ce que c'est viral
est-ce que c'est pas viral en tout cas
ça touche beaucoup les jeunes de moins
de 30 ans en France pratiquement 200000
c'est beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
monde touchés par cette maladie et et
c'est une maladie étrange parce que je
pense qu'il y a plein de gens qui savent
pas encore que j'ai cette maladie parce
qu'on voit ici et ça va et en fin de
compte j'ai du mal à marcher comme on
peut le voir et voilà c'est donc on s'en
occupe pas vraiment
c'est malheureusement le premier cas
d'invalidité après les accidents de la
route chez les jeunes c'est quand même
beaucoup c'est beaucoup et ça touche
beaucoup de jeunes et et et et mon
discours est simple c'est c'est aussi
redonner l'espoir à des gens qui sont
seuls chez eux qui nous regardent
sûrement ce soir et qui ont du mal à
aller dehors parce que moi c'est pas mon
problème c'est pas de de marcher parce
que je peux pas monter d'escalier c'est
que je peux pas marcher loin donc je
peux pas les prendre le bus donc je peux
pas me déplacer vraiment donc j'ai la
chance d'avoir quelqu'un qui vient
chercher tous les jours et d'avoir
quelqu'un qui à mes côtés mais si
j'avais pas cette personne là comment je
fais je reste chez moi
j'ai même un métro
alors je suis une maladie du système
nerveux centrale c'est-à-dire cerveau
nerf optique moelle épinière et en fait
c'est la destruction de la Méline
Lamyline c'est une gaine protectrice qui
entoure les neurones et l'influx nerveux
qui part du cerveau et maltransmis au
reste du corps en fait c'est ça
l'histoire oui c'est c'est la moelle
épinière c'est le le fil électrique qui
relie tout le corps et puis la gaine il
y a des trous dans la gaine voilà bah ça
fait court-circuit puis par moment on
voit plus ou on marche plus on peut plus
servir d'un bras ça revient ça s'en va
elle se recrée la myéline non
malheureusement c'est ça qu'on change
c'est c'est de recréer la myéline si on
recrée la myéline tout d'un coup tout va
bien et tout repart comme comme il y a
eu les premiers états généraux de la
sclérose en plaques le 28 avril dernier
et donc tu as tourné un clip toi de
sensibilisation en faveur de l'UNICEF
donc on va le regarder on va voir à quoi
ça ressemble tu vas regarder ta caméra
c'est le câble rouge et tu sais ce que
tu dois dire
Manitou Serge
[Musique]
allez
doucement
c'est pas moi c'est une doublure
moi je peux plus le faire la sclérose en
plaques est la première cause de
handicap chez les 25 35 ans après les
accidents de la route en France 80 000
personnes en sont atteintes et dominent
nouveaux casques en diagnostiqués chaque
année et des nou à la combattre
voilà
merci
qui m'a proposé ça et c'était on n'est
pas le siècle et l'idée c'était le début
que je sois acteur dedans et j'ai dit
non j'aimerais bien la mettre en scène
j'ai demandé à la mettre en scène parce
que je voulais aussi pouvoir en parler
en disant on peut faire des choses tout
en étant malade est-ce que c'est ça qui
m'importe c'est dire donner une chance
aux gens qui sont malades ils peuvent
bosser ils peuvent travailler donc c'est
pas parce que quelqu'un a la sclérose en
plaques qu'il faut absolument dire non
on va pas le prendre lui on va prendre
bien pourtant il y a des mecs qui
pensent j'ai pensé quelques années donc
ça ça marche encore et toi tu as une
activité absolument normale non oui oui
je me lève tôt le matin je me couche
tard le soir non non mais j'ai une
activité normale de producteur normale
je perd de l'argent tout ça ouais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu